hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to would you rather
now this one is hilarious in my opinion
spend one night passionately with Rosie
O'Donnell or have your two front teeth
pulled out now personally I got nothing
against Rosie O'Donnell and specifically
they're not really defining what
passionately means they don't say that
we're having sex or anything like that
it could be a passionate discussion it
could be a passionate kings of Badman it
could be a passionate game of Twister
that leads into a passion a night of
romp egde I mean I got I don't want my
two front teeth pulled out I like my two
front tooth loose I'll say I'll take the
passion at night it sounds I'll take
I'll take the Rosie O'Donnell I'm not a
[Music]
lot of people agree with me be a famous
homosexual professional athlete or be a
heterosexual average person I'm gonna
take the professional athlete what's the
difference if I'm homosexual that
doesn't change anything it just means
I'm just be job almost sexual that's all
that means but I'm famous and a
professional athlete so I'm hot as [ __ ]
and I'm famous I'll take that any day oh
yeah oh really oh really oh really 59%
of people would rather be an average
heterosexual person than be an awesome
homosexual person hey you all stay over
there in your stupidity zone how they're
to be here with the cool hot famous
people would you rather wear only skin
tight clothing or wear clothes that are
much too big well I mean if the last one
is anything to go by if I'm a famous
sports person in that I'm gonna be
wearing a lot of skin tag clothing I'm
gonna be bursting out of pretty much
everything you do thank God so I'll take
the skin tight I'll take the skin I'll
take the really tight clothing there
you know what I mean would you if you
had kids would you rather regurgitate
food to feed them or lick your children
to bathe them I'm thinking okay I'm
thinking that one a both are probably
couldn't traumatize my kids for life
let's just get that out of the way there
if I'm licking my children to bathe them
or I'm regurgitating food like one way
or another they're gonna be scarred for
life but number two I don't think that
society would accept either of these but
I think one of these society would
accept less than the other and I think
that's licking my children to bathe them
if I'm puking up my food if I just ate
it that foods practically good to eat
okay I'll pick the regurgitating but not
by a lot it's a it's pretty Club steel
here seems like people agree with me I
just don't I don't I got on it it'll be
that guy yeah that's bad either way okay
would you rather be visited by ancient
aliens or be visited by mole people
what do you mean ancient aliens what are
these the Romans of the aliens era and
that just so happened to stumble upon
earth like they're in their prehistoric
ancient alien times but they just happen
to be here
and I meet them the mole people however
that move them the mole people seems
interesting I mean one I have a lot of
questions of why there were more people
in the first place but if they're
anything like naked mole-rats put up a
picture of naked mole rats yeah they're
anything like that that ain't good ain't
gonna be good I'll take the ancient
aliens because the implication is
interesting it's how that app would you
rather never have to grocery shop again
or never have to do laundry again well
pretty much where I live I can get
groceries delivered to my door so that's
pretty nice but I still have to do
laundry so I'm gonna never having to do
longer again because [ __ ] bad I miss
living in my mom's basement
back with us first starting out you to
buy I lived in my mom's pretty much
basement and she did my laundry for me
and that was nice those nice times those
good times there's good time she also
did all the cooking so think of my mom's
house times were better back then I'll
take the laundry would you rather have
every song you lit ever listen to turn
ended nyan cat or every movie you ever
watched turn into Badgers Badgers
Badgers now are we talking about Badgers
Badgers Badgers Badgers Badgers because
that sounds awesome now on cat I'd get
pretty sick of that after a while and
and also I've taken the knew liking to
music and I don't want ed Sheeran to
suddenly start doubting out a ballot of
nyan cat there so I'll take the Badgers
because that's awesome oh you idiot oh
you idiots you don't know what you're
doing you don't know what you're
listening to
Badgers is amazing would you rather know
a few things about everything or know
everything but only about a few things
so you'd rather have a PhD or be that
guy that thinks they know everything I
don't know I'd rather know everything
about a few things cuz I don't think
that means I don't think that means oh
wait no wait no exploit okay if you know
a few things about everything did you
know things about topics that we as
humanity have not even discovered yet
you know a few things about aliens in
the universe you know a few things about
these subatomic particles you know a few
things about quantum theory you know a
few things about time travel you know a
few things about teleportation you know
a few things about alternate universes
you do so you know an infinite amount of
things technically because it means
everything every nuance of detail every
single person that ever lived
you know if do things about them you
know a few things about events that took
place in the past you may not know all
the details you don't know everything
but you know that it happened
you can at least say yes or no answer as
to whether something happened or not
that's that's a new way to look at that
question that I had thought of and I
think that's okay because if you know a
few things about absolutely everything
that you would know some things about
what not or what
I gotcha would you rather be the best
known person in a small band that under
200 people know or be some guy on the
sidelines of your favorite band you know
I'd rather be the best known person
because I actually you know what best
known doesn't mean best person in the
band you know you can be on the
sidelines or you can be the best known
person in a small band that doesn't mean
that you can't change your circumstances
but if you're on the sidelines of your
favorite band that gives you the most
opportunity to learn and it gives you
the most opportunity to experience that
because if my favorite band would say a
bigger band that toured around the world
then at least I would be able to
experience that like the best-known of
200 people if I'm on the sidelines of
the fame of my favorite band heck I'm
probably gonna be known by more than 200
people you know what I mean that doesn't
mean that I'm the most skilled but I'd
rather be on the sidelines of something
greater than a than a big fish in a very
very small time you know what I mean
would you rather be stuck in a room with
dead bodies or eat five spiders well how
long am i stuck in the room with dead
bodies and spiders are nutritious dammit
spiders are goddamn nutritious I eat a
spider I'll leave this spider anything
that will take that gel and give me the
spider oh you big babies begin in your
room with dead bodies
oh you weirdos you 59% is the same
people who'd rather be average imma
heterosexual people ah
it's people like you that are eating
spiders I hate spiders but I'll eat them
I'll eat the tiny ones little baby
spiders five baby spiders I'll get
put him in a pizza would you rather
always drive under the speeding limit or
always drive over the speed limit you
mean would I rather live my life the way
I don't live it or lift my life the way
I already do live it because that's kind
of oh oh no oh no I've been [ __ ] des
gonna hear really pointed up wouldn't
always driving over me not being able to
stop oh you're right
oh you're right always driving over
you're always doing that
oh no you're absolutely right I would
never be able to stop I'm stupid change
my answer would you rather never be able
to wear shoes or never be able to touch
anything red well by this question's own
logic I can't touch that red button if I
touch that red button
I can't I literally can't if I can't
touch anything right and I go with that
one I can't touch that button I mean I
know it's before hand but then what does
that even work if I accept that reality
I won't be able to touch that button I'm
in a conundrum of Perpetual Distortion
take the shoes alright would you rather
have the voice of the opposite sex or
have the muscle mass bodybuild of the
opposite sex
alright so this is interesting so
imagine me with a high-pitched feminine
voice and the body or imagine me with
the body build of a very elegant friend
very nice live frame I'm not sure which
one I would rather go I mean I like my
voice the way it is also I also have
been gifted with the genetic boon of
having
naturally muscular body which is good or
bad depending on the way you look at it
so I'll leave this question to you guys
which one of these would you rather have
you gotta pick one so get to picking so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think of this
question down the comments below and let
me know what you would choose as well
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]